being successful takes several different
variables I think self-awareness is
number one if you don't know yourself
and you don't know what you're good at
you've got no shot because you're gonna
be spinning your wheels are you willing
to be super honest with yourself when
nobody's watching we all know who we are
sometimes we don't like that what are
you actually good at what do you like
doing because the opportunities are
endless the problem is we are scared to
do different things because the
fundamental core reality is we worry
about getting judged if we fail like if
you're not your number one fan you've
lost because the Market's really good at
tearing you down every day 24 7
365 I will remind you that life is
phenomenal that nobody gives a [__] the
government or your mommy is not going to
help you you've got to do it own your
[__] but it's never been better we've
got a bigger chance than ever we can do
our thing we're really [__] strong
we're just being sold that we're not
because there's a lot of money in
telling us that we're not good enough I
want to tell you you're the [__] best
go do [__]